sean g y h funciones inversas y
recordemos rápidamente que significa que
dos funciones sean inversas significa
que si tenemos dos conjuntos de números
y si pensamos que este primer conjunto
es el dominio de la función g y bueno
podemos empezar por aquí con un punto x
que va a mandar a este valor x a otro
valor que se llama g de x ok esto es lo
que hace la función g pero ahora si h es
la función inversa de g y sucede lo
mismo si intercambiamos los nombres pero
si h es la función inversa de g
entonces h va a mandar a este otro punto
a x h nos regresaría al valor original
así es que por un lado a este punto le
podemos llamar x
pero por otro lado también le podemos
llamar h deje de equis h deje de equis
hice este dibujo por aquí para
explicarte muy a fondo qué es lo que
está pasando y estés de acuerdo cuando
yo escriba que h de eje de x es igual a
equis y de la otra forma también g de h
de x también es igual a x aunque ya que
pusimos este x por acá pero pudimos
haber empezado por acá en este diagrama
podríamos simplemente cambiar la h por
la g así es que también podemos decir
que g de h de x es igual a equis y luego
nos dan aquí un poco más de información
nos dan una lista con algunos valores de
g h i g prima y lo que nos piden es que
encontremos h prima de 3 pero aquí no
nos dan la función h prima de x ni
siquiera nos dan la función h completa
así es que cómo le hacemos para
encontrar este valor
única información que tenemos son estos
dos valores de g prima de h y de g como
le vamos a hacer para encontrar h prima
de 3 bueno pues vamos a hacer algo muy
interesante derivado de la regla de la
cadena y este no es un problema que te
vayas a encontrar muy seguido pero es un
problema muy interesante así es que lo
vamos a resolver y bueno también puede
ser que lo encuentres en tu clase de
cálculo vamos a empezar con alguna de
estas dos expresiones creo que vamos a
empezar con esta expresión
tenemos que g de h de x es igual a equis
y bueno esto es cierto siempre que sean
funciones inversas y ahora vamos a sacar
la derivada con respecto de x de ambos
lados y para encontrar esta derivada lo
que tenemos que hacer es usar las
y la de la cadena que nos dice que está
derivada es igual a g prima de h de x
por h prima de x ésta es la derivada del
lado izquierdo fue simplemente aplicar
la regla de la cadena aquí y tiene que
ser igual a la derivada con respecto de
x de x pero eso a cuanto es igual bueno
pues esto es igual a 1 es bastante
interesante porque ve por ejemplo aquí
nosotros queremos encontrar h prima de 3
porque queremos encontrar h prima de 3
para eso podemos encontrar h de tres y
lo que sea que no salga aquí el valor
hd3 cualquiera que sea ese lo podemos
utilizar para encontrar que prima de ese
valor y ya que tengamos esta parte
resuelta entonces ya vamos a saber
exactamente cuánto es h prima de 3 pero
bueno para no estar
confundiendo tanto deberíamos
describirlo de una forma más directa
porque tenemos que h prima de x es igual
a 1 entre g prima de h de x en algunos
lugares van a recomendarte que te
aprendas de memoria esta fórmula y eso
puede llegar a ser útil por ejemplo para
resolver estos ejercicios de khan
academy sería útil aprenderse la pero yo
por ejemplo hace más o menos 25 años que
tomé el curso de cálculo y este tipo de
información
las fórmulas la verdad no es el tipo de
cosas que mi memoria a largo plazo
retiene yo no me acordaba de esta
fórmula pero de lo que sí me acordé
perfectamente es de cómo obtenerla a
partir de la definición de funciones
inversas
y de la regla de la cadena pero bueno
utilicemos esta fórmula para encontrar h
prima de 3 h prima de 3 es igual a 1 /
que prima de h de 3 y yo la verdad estoy
suponiendo que nos dieron estos valores
a ver vamos a buscar h de tres cuando x
es igual a 3 h es igual a 4 pies que hd
3 es igual a 4 y ahora nada más tenemos
que encontrar cuánto es que prima de 4
ok pero afortunadamente nos dieron ese
valor cuando x es igual a 4 que prima de
x es un medio entonces que prima de 4
un medio a ver entonces h prima de 3 es
igual a 1 entre un medio pero 1 entre un
medio es igual a 2 y listo ya terminamos
h prima de 3 es 2